élections régionales et cantonales
l'ancien secrétaire général du rpr jean
françois mancel exclu du mouvement
gaulliste il avait accepté les avances
du front national dans son département
de l'oise
huit cent croient d'un cimetière
arrachés dans le gers des sectes
sataniques groupe en france plusieurs
milliers d'adeptes
comment sérieusement inquiéter les
services de police 60% des français
ignorent tout des langues étrangères
le ministre de l'éducation claude
allègre de les enseigner à partir du
cours moyen
ouverture à berlin aujourd'hui du procès
des faiseurs de champion de l'ex
allemagne de l'est pour obtenir des
médailles sont accusés d'avoir mis la
vie des athlètes en jeu enquête dans ce
journal bourguinat est un film drôle
émouvant sur un sujet pourtant difficile
les mésaventures d'une star du cinéma x
américain ce film est considéré comme
l'un des favoris dans la course aux
oscars à hollywood
madame monsieur bonsoir en france la
perspective des élections de présidents
de conseils régionaux vendredi
continuent d'agiter la classe politique
principalement à droite
suite aux consignes très strictes donné
par le rpr et l'udf de n'accepter en
aucun cas une alliance avec le front
national
des tractations continuent malgré tout
dans certaines régions en secret dans
une autre - en plein jour c'est le cas
de la picardie et de l'oise pour qui ce
compte pour ce qui concerne la une
élection cantonale et la surprise est
venue cet après midi avec l'exclusion de
l'ancien secrétaire général du rpr jean
françois mancel qui avait ouvertement
jugé acceptable
les offres de soutien du front national
reportage j'ai vite albert rémy
poissonnier c'était la déclaration de
trop
le front national doit devenir une
partie de la droite de demain a dit jean
françois mancel
la semaine dernière il en appelait aux
voix d'extrême droite pour être ré ce
soir philippe séguin prononce une
exclusion qui fait du bruit
jean françois mancel était le numéro
deux du rpr il y encore un an
on le présentait alors comme un proche
d'alain juppé les liaisons droite
extrême droite sont devenus la grande
spécialité de l'oise
département de jean françois mancel
pierre descaves un vieux fidèle de
jean-marie le pen à qui sait les
premiers liens aujourd'hui des
négociations électorales
mais depuis déjà longtemps un climat de
grande courtoisie sur le terrain n'y a
pas de blocage c'est sur le terrain je
peux si j'en ai envie d sculpté avec
monsieur marini je peux discuter avec
monsieur mancelle
je peux rencontrer n'importe quel leader
du rpr ou de l'udf sans avoir de refus
de rebuffades exclusive de l'exclusion
tout ça
cité par pierre descaves philippe marini
qui est un des leaders du rpr local
conteste la tenue de discussions avec le
fn mais il reconnaît qu'il ya bien une
nouvelle donne nos électeurs voir
renaître aujourd'hui une certaine idée
de la droite on n'a plus honte de
s'affirmer de droite est de moins en
moins on en aura honte
le prochain enjeu se déroule ici au
conseil régional de picardie dont
l'actuel président l'udf charles baur
laisse entendre qu'il acceptera après
demain les voix de l'extrême droite pour
rester dans son fauteuil
ce ne sera pas la première fois de 86 à
92 charles baur a déjà dirigé la région
picardie avec l'appoint du fn
cette fois ci en cas de majorité
relative la région devrait basculer à
gauche au profit du parti communiste
selon les arbitrages rendus par matignon
mais là aussi le fn a jeté le trias que
avec le front national
on ne s'arrête pas à quelques quelques
idées le front national n'a par tra
passé voilà les régions gratuitement il
faudra appliquer son programme
les militants du front national n'ont
jamais eu autant de travail il ya des
candidats à faire élire dimanche dans
cette région
ils n'ont jamais été si courtisé
dans la région centre à un autre
scénario est en train de s'écrire la
tête de liste rpr udf est débordé par
certains de ses colistiers qui ont
entrepris des tractations avec des
représentants du front national
reportage michaël darmon patrick démunis
opel de région d'orléans à chacun son
style de réunion michel sapin tête de
liste de la gauche plurielle accueille
les élus devant la presse
trois sièges d'avancé sur le papier il
peut être élu président de la région
à droite aussi on tenait réunion mais en
catimini et les journalistes étaient
plutôt indésirables comme pour le rpr y
fromion
vraiment mais salopards de la fin de la
chanson assez nerveuse à droite en
région centre carrière de négociateur du
front national ont rencontré des élus
rpr udf et on va recevoir les
ambassadeurs entre guillemets les les
ambassadeurs qui sont allés discuter
avec le fn y vont ils vont nous faire
part des desiderata des du fn et des
heures de débat cours desquelles la tête
de liste udf renaud donnedieu de vabres
opposé depuis toujours un accord avec le
front national se trouverait de plus en
plus isolé oui je le dis le front
national existe et si on refuse de
discuter avec le front national et bien
il faut l'interdire entre les élus rpr
et udf ou pensions serait très forte et
en fin d'après-midi personne n'a envie
de communiquer je suis chargé de vous
dire au nom des deux délégations qu'il
n'y aura pas d'autres déclarations
officielles ce soit la droite seraient
attirés par le front national et la
gauche elle lance un avertissement c'est
qu'ils sont de savoir si la droite
acceptera de se faire manger car c'est
elle qui se fera manger par le front
national ou si elle est dans le camp de
ceux qui résistent aux comptes
alors y aura-t-il un accord entre la
droite et les 13 élus frontistes dans la
région centre nul ne le sait pour
l'instant
mais à moins d'un coup de théâtre la
digue anti fn de la droite parlementaire
semble ici sur le point de céder à noter
encore que pour éviter toute candidature
de compromis avec le front national à
droite le président du rpr philippe
séguin a demandé à françois lyotard de
se présenter à la présidence de la
région provence alpes côte d'azur
même s'il n'a aucune chance d'être élus
ces derniers auraient accepté les
élections des présidents de conseils
régionaux allant se jouer parfois une
voix près personne et est indifférent
cet après midi à la réunion des
chasseurs 31 élus dans toute la france
le sort de trois régions rhône-alpes
poitou charentes et franche-comté dépend
en effet de leur vote pour l'instant ils
ont décidé de ne pas choisir entre
droite et gauche mais de voter contre
partout il ya des écologistes en
position d'être élu à des postes de
responsabilité comme des vice
présidences qui ont été promises par le
parti socialiste
et puis enfin en marge de ces élections
l'annoncent par matignon d'un
remaniement manistes ministériel dans
les semaines à venir en fonction des
choix que certains ministres élus auront
à faire entre un mandat local régional
et leur place au gouvernement
le phénomène des groupes ou des sectes
qui se réclament du satanisme ou de
l'adoration du diable commence à
inquiéter sérieusement les services de
police en effet il ya 48 heures à peine
ce sont 800 croix d'un cimetière d'une
commune du gers qui ont été arrachées
ces groupes sont en général constitué de
quelques adolescents en quête d'une
forme d'originalité à défaut de
personnalités il n'en reste pas moins
qu'ils peuvent se révéler dangereux
eric lemasson et rick george c'est
samedi dernier au petit matin que les
gardiens du cimetière de l'isle jourdain
dans le gers ont découvert ce saccage
pas moins de 800 croit décrocher des
pierres tombales dans une allée une
carcasse de poulet faisait office de
signature diabolique les prières et là
aux jeunes des environs ont été
interpellés ils ont reconnu être les
auteurs de ce pseudo rituel satanique
beaucoup plus loin dans l'ignominie
emilie 19 ans devant ses juges à toulon
c'était en octobre dernier la jeune
fille et ses trois amis adeptes de satan
ont fini par demander pardon mais leurs
actes avaient démontré l'absence totale
de limites profanation ouverture du
cercueil mutilation d'un cadavre à coups
de crucifix paul ariès cet universitaire
spécialiste des sectes titre de son
ouvrage le retour du diable on a affaire
effectivement à des groupes sporadiques
qui secret qui se défont et qui se
reconstitue très rapidement dans lequel
effectivement les jeunes ont perdu toute
référence à l'effet étoiles et notre
grande amie cette maison
la fascination pour le malin ne date pas
d'hier c'est par opposition aux lois de
l'église que les adorateurs de lucifer
se regroupaient autrefois célébrant
messes noires et orgies de façon
inoffensive
le nouveau visage des satanistes et tout
autre violent politisé aussi à l'extrême
droite
car la frontière est étroite entre le
culte du diable et celui d'hitler
le mois dernier c'est tout un réseau
néonazis satanistes qui a été démantelé
par les gendarmes
huit mille jeunes graviterait autour de
ces groupuscules estimations des
renseignements généraux groupuscules qui
recrutent parmi les amateurs de musique
dark metal ou death metal on a les
adeptes de base qui sont généralement
des paumés qui sont des gens qui n'ont
pas de pouvoir sur leur vie qu'ils
n'auront jamais de pouvoir sur la vie en
général et pour qui finalement la
croyance au diable si une sorte de
prothèse par cette croyance il s'imagine
effectivement avoir enfin au pouvoir le
pouvoir de vie et de mort parfois au
mois de décembre
le curé du village alsacien de
kingersheim a été assassiné de 33 coups
de couteau un jeune paumé de 19 ans a
mis des profanateurs de toulon a avoué
le crime crimes commis at-il expliqué au
nom de satan une dizaine de jeunes gens
masqués ont attaqué lundi soir un train
de marchandises dans la banlieue de
marseille contraignant le convoi à
s'arrêter la sncf reste discrète sur les
conséquences commerciales de cette
attaque qui apparemment n'est pas la
première du genre en reportage indycar
ou si jean françois georges et
aujourd'hui les trains de marchandises
passent sans encombre sur le bord de la
voie
voici les pierres et blocs de béton
utilisé avant-hier par une quinzaine de
jeunes pour stopper un train de
marchandises alors je suis sortie de la
machine mais je ne suis pas allé plus
loin car ces mêmes jeunes m'attendais
avec des cailloux à la main tant que je
ne suis pas pu aller voir ce qui s'est
passé sur train à ce moment là que si
vous avez fait même par la vie de j ai
regardé et j'ai vu qu'ils étaient sûrs
qu'ils commencent à offrir un container
jeu puis les serrer le frein du train
est reparti un maigre butin pour les
voleurs le wagon contenait des haricots
secs mais incidents sont fréquents sur
cette partie de voie du 15e
arrondissement de marseille
facile d'accès le chemin de fer est
souvent utilisée comme raccourci par les
jeunes du quartier
ça fait un mois que j'avais dit j'ai
passé là bas et j'ai de ces titres est
arrêtée au drapeau basque qui traversent
le tunnel et les traîne pour pas qu'il y
ait d'accident
pourtant la police ferroviaire
patrouillent régulièrement mais les
effectifs sont insuffisants
il y à 40 km de réseau ferré dans la
ville de marseille des clôtures sont
installés le long des voies
le plus souvent en pure perte
malheureusement ces clôtures
bien que quelques fois construite par
des jeunes du quartier ont été déterrés
par d'autres jeunes de quartiers passage
libre ou presque
les jets de pierre sur la voie sont
fréquents et les attaques des convois
qui roule à 60 à l'heure sont au nombre
de trois ou quatre par an à chaque fois
la sncf porte plein puis opération de
police ce matin en banlieue parisienne à
chanteloup-les-vignes dans les yvelines
et policiers étaient à la recherche des
auteurs du saccage d'un train de
banlieue samedi dernier entre la gare
saint lazare et mantes-la-jolie six
personnes ont été placées en garde à vue
à ajaccio hier soir a eu lieu une
reconstitution du meurtre du préfet
claude erignac reconstitution sous haute
surveillance policière derrière des
palissades en présence de trois juges
antiterroristes dirigé par jean louis
bruguière pour la première fois des
témoins directs ont pu s'exprimer sur
les circonstances de l'assassinât au
procès de maurice papon à bordeaux on
approche du terme des débats avec les
réquisitions de l'avocat général et du
procureur en deux temps dont aujourd'hui
et demain
l'avocat général a décrit cet après-midi
le fonctionnaire maurice papon sans
complaisance dominique verdeilhan oui un
réquisitoire en deux épisodes vous
l'avait dit et 6h pour dresser le
portrait sans surprise d'un carriériste
vichyssois d'un fonctionnaire sans états
d'âme d'un homme de l'ombre par
excellence
l'avocat général marc robert signale que
pour lui maurice papon est un trafiquant
de la réalité un manipulateur de la
mémoire la résistance est dit-il
l'antidote de l'accusé or on ne peut pas
à la fois résisté et déportés enfin marc
robert dénonce les propos je cite
mensongers et intolérable de maurice
papon sur les sauvetage des juifs
or le magistrat rappelle que nous
n'avons aucun témoignage de juifs sauvés
par l'accusé dans le dossier tant
dominique rien n'indique dans le
réquisitoire d'aujourd'hui quelle
sentence va être demandée demain soir
non car derrière ces mots sans
concession il est résident
et nuancée certaines victimes ne cache
pas ce soir lors inquiétudes d'abord
elles craignent un saucissonnage c'est
leur expression autrement dit on
maintient des convois et des victimes
pour en écarter d'autres faute de
preuves
enfin elle note que l'avocat général
fait un distinguo très nette entre
maurice papon et rené bousquet l'ancien
secrétaire général de la police à vichy
un discours qui n'est pas sans rappeler
celui d'arno klarsfeld qui la semaine
dernière préconisait une peine mesurée
mais ce n'est que demain soir que l'on
saura si l'accusation requiert ou non la
perpétuité
merci dominique le financement politique
maintenant une condamnation à trois ans
de prison ferme pour robert bourachot
ancien président ni société de travaux
publics qui avaient alimenté plusieurs
parcours politique sans que les
bénéficiaires et jamais est clairement
désigné retrouver et mise en bourse une
des quatre personnes interpellées la
suite du meurtre de la fille d'un
notaire de la région lilloise a avoué
avoir étranglé la victime quelques
heures à peine après son enlèvement la
semaine dernière et avant même d'avoir
envoyé une demande de rançon aux parents
apparemment d'après les aveux
enregistrés l'assassinât avait été
soigneusement programmés et préméditée
reportage virginie pichet dominique maes
ce soir sébastien choderlos 24 ans
dormira en prison
présenté au parquet cet après midi il a
été mis en examen pour assassinat et
séquestration
avec demande de rançon son demi frère et
complice jérôme lucas 26 ans et toujours
détenus en belgique sous le même chef
d'inculpation aux prises avec des
problèmes financiers les deux frères
avaient échafaudé l'enlèvement de
caroline pour se renflouer
deux frères devenus deux assassins de
sang froid la mort de caroline poser
partie de leur projet dès le début le
dit bien d'ailleurs
dans sa déclaration jérôme lucas j'avais
pris dès le début la résolution
d'assassiner caroline car elle me
connaissait d'une part et d'autre part
il m'est est matériellement impossible
de l'aga tenir en toute sécurité
le 5 mars caroline le gentil se rend
sans méfiance à un rendez-vous fixé par
jérôme son ancien petit ami près de ce
bar du doigt fermé depuis décembre
l'établissement appartient à sébastien
ramené il hier sur les lieux
les choses vont ensuite très vite
immobilisé à l'aide de ruban adhésif la
jeune fille est d'abord séquestré le
temps pour ses ravisseurs de prendre des
photos envoyées à ses parents deux
heures à peine après son arrivée
caroline est morte les deux frères ont
étranglés machiavélique il avait même
creusé la tombe de leurs victimes
plusieurs jours auparavant
ce n'est qu'une fois leur forfait commis
que les deux assassins ont exigé une
rançon d'un million de francs ce soir
ils sont tous deux passés aux aveux
les deux autres suspects interpellés
lundi ont été remis en liberté
la demande d'extradition de jérôme lucas
devrait intervenir dans les gens d'al
oula les français ont l'habitude de dire
qu'ils sont quelque peu hermétique aux
langues étrangères et les statistiques
démontrent que 60% d'entre nous sont
incapables de lire ou d'écrire une seule
langue étrangère un défaut qui
s'explique peut-être par le fait que
notre langue a été pendant longtemps
l'une des plus parlées dans le monde
ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui l'autre
raison est plus simple et plus difficile
à résoudre l'enseignement des langues
vivantes dans notre pays reste très
académique
c'est pour cette raison après d'autres
que le ministre de l'éducation claude
allègre a présenté aujourd'hui un plan
de réformes visant à instaurer dès le
cours moyen dès le primaire donc l'étude
d'une langue étrangère principalement
l'anglais bien entendu thibault de
barbeyrac nathalie moisi
ah oui en or to get lyon
ils sont cadres supérieurs mais il
retourne à l'école aujourd'hui pour
conquérir de nouveaux marchés
les grandes entreprises françaises sont
obligés de payer des stages d'anglais à
leurs employés en france même les plus
diplômés ne maîtrise pas bien les
langues étrangères
on est un pays qui a une grande histoire
qui est une très belle langue et donc on
est parvenu par rapport à ça mais je
crois que c'est ça tient certainement
système éducatif pour apprendre
facilement il faut commencer dès le plus
jeune âge si possible dès l'école
primaire
le premier à avoir appliqué ce principe
c'est lionel jospin alors ministre de
l'éducation des instits qui ne
maîtrisent pas de langue étrangère peu
de moyens la méthode jospin échoue comme
celle de son successeur françois bayrou
qui remplace les professeurs par des
cassettes vidéo
les cassettes vous pourrez choisir
l'image c'est une poupée gonflable ou
via une bouée de sauvetage
mais ça ne peut être en aucun cas
l'outil unique pour apprendre les
langues à son tour claude allègre
annonce un nouveau plan dès la rentrée
prochaine en cm2 les enfants suivront un
apprentissage aux langues étrangères
apprentissage assurés par des
professeurs du secondaire des emplois
jeunes ou des assistants étrangers
en ce qui concerne le financement du
plan en revanche le ministre n'en parle
même pas c'est un nouveau plan d'
annonce et on considère aujourd'hui que
le ministre prend ses désirs pour des
réalités
il veut généraliser en 98-99
l'apprentissage en cm1 et cm2 et on n'a
pas les moyens aujourd'hui de le faire
les moyens ce serait des instituteurs
mieux formés
aujourd'hui seulement 13 % d'entre eux
s'estiment capables d'enseigner une
langue étrangère alors parfois de
comparaison la france occupait une
position particulière dans le domaine de
l'apprentissage des langues
oui par rapport à un autre pays comme
l'allemagne par exemple berlin
olivier dernière d'abord un jeu qui
donne le goût d'apprendre comme en
france c'est à l'âge de 11 ans que les
petits allemands font leurs premiers pas
dans une langue étrangère
mais leur motivation est sans conteste
plus forte que dans les écoles de la
république
ici ils le savent
communiquer avec le monde entier il faut
maîtriser une langue internationale
les plus grands sont chaque année plus
nombreux dans les écoles de langues un
million d'allemands apprennent l'anglais
300000 le français plus d'un allemand
sur deux maîtrisent une langue étrangère
nous les allemands au voyage dans le
bundle
mais pour cela il faut parler anglais à
l'université j'ai appris l'anglais le
français et le russe et j'ai fait du
latin aussi l'allemand on peut
simplement le parler en autriche et en
allemagne
on n'est pas en amérique du sud aux
états unis 90 % des allemands apprennent
l'anglais mais combien le parcours avant
ça c'est une autre question
la culture la musique l'économie les
allemands sont grands ouverts
aujourd'hui sur l'étranger dans les
entreprises ou les grands magasins on
pose systématiquement cette condition
avant l' embauche
l'employé doit parler anglais depuis la
chute du mur en 89
l'apprentissage de la langue de
shakespeare commence dès l'âge de 8 ans
dans certains établissements ou chantent
déjà frérot jacques en anglais et en
allemand
ils seront bilingues on en fabrique
l'entreprise france télécom qui vient
d'être en partie privatisée affiche pour
l'année dernière un bénéfice record de
14 9 milliards de francs contre
seulement 2 milliards l'année précédente
en 96 france télécom est le 4ème
opérateur téléphonique dans le monde des
angles il y a quelques années de cela on
pensait que face à la concurrence
asiatique japonaises coréennes les
chantiers navals français allait mourir
les uns après les autres
certains ont disparu certes mais
d'autres survivent et revivent même
c'est le cas des chantiers de
l'atlantique à saint nazaire qui se sont
fait une spécialité du paquebot de luxe
du paquebot de rêve quatre nouvelles
commandes viennent d'être signés avec
des armateurs des caraïbes à saint
nazaire les 4000 salariés de
l'entreprise ont acquis un savoir faire
dans tous les domaines qui est reconnu
dans le monde entier
jacques devaux gabriel kane
à bord du vision des mères on en est aux
travaux de finition le dernier né des
chantiers sera livré dans un mois et
1000 personnes s'affairent soucieuse du
moindre détail du confort y avait
calcule t c ur et par le fait que tout
est posé bon je suis petit cochon
connaître ses vendeurs
car cette soupe mais il descend le
dessin d'un bon il faudrait vérifier sur
tous les vents calmes sur un meuble
problème ou pas et il en va ainsi depuis
près de 15 ans gbagbo a fait paquebot
les chantiers qui ont construit de
france se sont forgé une solide
réputation de qualité et de savoir-faire
on est un petit peu de nous donc on
essaie de faire c'est toujours
satisfaisant mais tout n'est pas
qu'affaire de qualité sylla rccl vient
de commander de nouveaux paquebots alors
que le vision ne lui ai pas encore
livrés c'est que les chantiers ont
promis des délais plus courts et des
prix plus serré c'est pas travailler
plus vite c'est travailler mieux il ya
des questions d'organisation
il ya des questions de répartition du
travail entre nous et d'autres sous
traitants
il ya la façon dont nous concevons des
navires il ya les investissements que
nous faisons tout ça de contribuer à
l'amélioration de nos un plan qui
inquiète les syndicats
même si avec 10 gbagbo à construire il y
à du travail assuré pour deux ans mais
construire moins cher et aussi bien est
la condition de la survie des chantiers
et ce pari est loin d'être gagné
dans l' affaire de pots-de-vin à propos
de la vente de matériels militaires
français à taiwan à laquelle notamment
le nom de roland dumas est mêlé le
gouvernement de taïwan a décidé de
bloquer le dernier versement dû à ce
jour en attendant que cette affaire soit
réglée
en france la commission de bruxelles va
proposer aux ministres de l'agriculture
de l'union européenne une baisse des
prix garantis aux agriculteurs -30% pour
la viande bovine -20% pour les céréales
- 15 % pour les produits laitiers il
s'agit de s'adapter à la concurrence
mondiale en contrepartie de la baisse de
ces aides collective des aides directes
vont être attribués mais qui ne
compenseront pas totalement c'est beth
collectif d'une manière générale les
agriculteurs français sont donc inquiets
de ces décisions en perspective
reportage dans une exploitation de la
région lyonnais didier guyot jean claude
martin saint claude whissell dans le
département du rhône
c'est ici que sur quelques 110 ha pascal
poyet et son père alexis dirige une
exploitation agricole avec 200 bêtes un
peu de maïs et de blé des emprunts et
des investissements en matériel ils se
battent au quotidien pour que la ferme
tourbe hausse il annonce d'une baisse de
prix garantis
la perspective d'être européenne plus
faible de compensation - sorte a de quoi
les inquiéter baisse des prix n'a pas
entièrement compensé
on parle de chasse en disposant du
compte des consignes de compensation ce
qui indique sur nos revenus ça va être
300 points d'où la nécessité de trouver
d'autres productions ou autre je ne sais
pas ce qu'on va faire 30 % de revenus en
moins étalées sur quelques années il va
falloir compenser ce manque à gagner en
limitant les investissements en faisant
d'autres productions comme la volaille
ou le port difficile en tout cas pour
pascal 27 ans d'apprécier cet
environnement européen qui fait qu'à lui
le producteur on demande toujours de
baisser les prix c'est vrai que ça fait
mal au coeur d'entendre les
les gens nous dire oui vous manifester
en choeur vous n'êtes pas contents
d'être si vous êtes là on a du mal à
vivre de notre métier et c'est ça qui
est désolant maintenant à l'heure
actuelle l'exploitation dégage un peu
plus de 200 mille francs de revenus par
an 200 mille francs pour faire vivre
quatre personnes mais il ya aussi tous
les emprunts remboursés
le gouvernement ne veut pas de nouvelle
affaire saint-bernard ce matin dans le
xviiie arrondissement de paris une
église occupée a été évacué au bout
d'une heure à peine c'est la quatrième
tentative d'occupation des sans papiers
depuis une quinzaine de jours maintenant
seul l'occupation de la cathédrale
d'evry se poursuit aujourd'hui à berlin
s'est ouvert le premier procès des
responsables sportifs de l'ex allemagne
de l'est rda
plusieurs entraîneurs athlètes médaillés
olympiques auront à répondre méthode
employée pour que ce fait il se peut
citer ou de 17 millions d'habitants
rafle des dizaines et des dizaines de
médailles et records en tout genre
tout de suite après des nations de plus
de 200 millions d'habitants comme
lecture ss ou encore les états où il
faut dire que pour les dirigeants
communistes de l'époque le sport était
une arme politique internationale et que
tout était admis à condition de réussir
même mettre en jeu la vie des athlètes
reportage olivier l'ère des épaules de
déménageur défi couverte de médailles
d'or 100 82 titres internationaux entre
1966 et 1989 avec le maillot de la ddr
l'ex allemagne de l'est
ricard heinich a enlevé trois médailles
olympiques en 1980 à moscou 8 mer
regardez c'est quand même sous d'avoir
un corps pareil au lac gelé bien connu
aujourd'hui elle à vinci et a perdu tous
ses muscles à la
dix mille athlètes est-allemand ont été
dopés rheinische est la première à avoir
déposé plainte contre son entraîneur
voilà les pilules que nous prenions que
c'était des pilules bleues nous devions
en aval et hilton je me souviens bien
c'est aussi des piqûres
c'était des anabolisants stéroïdes des
images tournées en 1976 par la stasi la
police secrète à l'intention des
médecins et des entraîneurs qui devaient
eux-mêmes piquer leur champion la stasi
transformé en véritable laboratoire de
recherche médicale avec un seul objectif
améliorer les performances des sportifs
pour décrocher des médailles
les entraîneurs rémunérés par la stasi
en fonction des résultats obtenus en
compétition était en fait de véritables
agents secrets ils ont multiplié les
rapports sous leur nom de code mais
aujourd'hui ils ont été des masques le
facho quiète et je n'ai vrai choc quand
j'ai appris que mon entraîneur était un
agent de la stasi
je savais qu'il y avait toujours des
agents secrets
mais je ne me pose pas beaucoup de
questions à l'époque j'avais 14 ans il a
vraiment abusé de la confiance il faut
emprunter les grands boulevards de
berlin est pour se rendre dans les
locaux de l'ancienne police secrète qui
est resté là où elle était impossible en
effet de déménager 180 km de dossiers le
dopage
une tricherie à grande échelle
orchestrée par les responsables
politiques de la république démocratique
allemande et contrôler de a à z par la
stasi
le programme de dopage de l'ex rda est
ici dévoilée par l'ouverture de ses
archives
dopage c'était une politique d'état rate
il y avait un vrai plan pour développer
les produits trouvés les substances qui
pouvaient augmenter l'efficacité des
sports à chaud toutes les disciplines
étaient concernés nous en avons la
preuve
40 millions de fiches aujourd'hui chacun
peut voir la sienne depuis la chute du
mur en 89
l'ancienne stasi collaborent avec la
justice et recolle les papiers un
gigantesque puzzle
dix sept mille sacs 250 mille pages
reconstituer la machine à broyer encore
sur place n'a pas tout avaler la stasi
contrôler la taille des enfants dès
l'âge de 6 ans pour détecter les talents
le plus tôt possible des tests étaient
pratiqués avec toujours cette idée
d'utiliser les performances comme une
arme de lutte idéologique connaissait la
rda partout dans le monde grâce au sport
et à nos victoires mais tous les
champions se dopait chez nous ce système
était entièrement basé là dessus on
était les représentants des temps vrai
diplomate en maillot de bain mais tout
le monde n'a pas eu le courage de
dénoncer ce système qui a fait la gloire
de ce pays et de quelques jeunes filles
christine auto plusieurs fois médaillé
olympique a été décoré aussi par erich
honecker pour services rendus à la
nation
christine automne n'a jamais avoué
qu'elle s'était dopée mais un document
qui date de 89 la teste la nageuse à un
taux très élevé d'hormones masculines à
l'est contrôlées positives
les entraîneurs mise en accusation sont
toujours en exercice en france en
autriche et en allemagne
on les voit ici devant le parquet de
berlin ils vont devoir répondre de
blessures corporelles par administration
de produits dopants sur mineurs un
procès riche d'enseignements nouvelle
manifestation aujourd'hui au kosovo
cinquante mille personnes dans les rues
de pristina la ville la plus importante
de la province
également un drame dans une autre ville
à pécs où des policiers serbes ont tué
un manifestant est blessé et plusieurs
jours le jour même où le leader des
albanais du kosovo accepte enfin décidé
de discuter pardon pour la première fois
non plus d'indépendance pour la province
mais simplement d'autos neuves aux états
unis la sphère des démêlés de bill
clinton avec un certain nombre de jeunes
femmes n'ont aucune répercussion jusqu'à
présent sur sa cote de popularité qui
n'a jamais été aussi haute
pour autant les américains restent
toujours très choqué par d'éventuels
mensonges de la part de qui que ce soit
fût-il le premier chef d'état du monde
washington
maryse de monica levinsky prenant
l'ascenseur monica lewinsky assistant
hier soir avec son avocat à un match de
basket ball
l'ex stagiaire de la maison blanche ne
fait plus un pas sans être filmé
eyrolles filmé et le public américain
n'en peut plus de ce scandale sexuel à
feuilleton les femmes en particulier
distant corps majoritairement que les
frasques de leur président ne les
intéresse pas mais alors pas du tout
ranspach fait très important parce que
je pense que c'est plus important ce qui
fait avec l'appui et je pense qu'il est
un très bon président un président très
célèbre dans le passé bien connu pour
avoir une esclave comme m c'est comme ça
depuis toujours les derniers sondages
montrent toujours une excellente cote de
popularité pour bill clinton
et cela même si les dernières
révélations de catherine ouellet ont
modifié quelques opinions d'entendre ces
choses obscène qui sont arrivés dans son
bureau avec des gens qui venaient
demande un travail qui travaillaient
déjà gouvernement oui vraiment sage
désapprouve la plupart des experts
professeurs et autres commentateurs qui
dissèque en permanence l'état de
l'opinion publique constate qu'en fait
elle n'a guère évolué depuis
l'éclatement du scandale en janvier
l'économie va bien la bourse atteint un
sommet la criminalité est en baisse et
la consommation des drogues aussi il y a
même moins de cancers que le président
est donc une belle marge de manoeuvre
les fans américaines comptent
habituellement sans profession en
matière de harcèlement sexuel
le nombre de poursuites judiciaires en
la matière est ici phénoménal mais il
semble que pour bill clinton elle soit
prête à pardonner en tout cas pour
l'enfant est temps que l'économie va
bien
une sorte de travaux d'hercule à paris
avec le coup d'envoi officiel
aujourd'hui du déménagement de la
bibliothèque nationale la rue de
richelieu au tour de la très grande
bibliothèque de tolbiac 10 millions
d'ouvragés vont être transférés le
déménagement durera jusqu'au début de
l'année prochaine reportage benoît
mousset dominique merde c'est désormais
le passé la splendide salle de lecture
de la bibliothèque richelieu va perdre
une grosse partie de ses trésors
demain changement de décor les
rayonnages de la bibliothèque françois
mitterrand accueilleront plus de 10
millions d'ouvragés
le déménagement du siècle 130km de
volume à vider soit 450 m par jour le
tout en dix mois
pour respecter les délais ce 50 gros
bras en cadence soutenue pour ces
déménageurs spécialisés en la matière du
plus précieux des manuscrits à
l'encyclopédie rare tous les livres vont
passer entre leurs mains
ici
autre impératif la sécurité des
collections là un véritable plan de
bataille a été mise en place
armoires roulante anti vibrations et
anti feu des mesures draconiennes mais
indispensable et ensuite par des
systèmes de goven de matières plastiques
le polystyrène je ne sais trop quoi on
immobilise les livres intérieur avant de
fermer les portes coupe-feu et de
scellés ça donc je crois pas normalement
il ne doit pas y avoir de risque ni de
fuite de livres ni incendie ni
l'innovation
sécurité également à l'extérieur seul la
préfecture de police connaît
l'itinéraire des quasi les camions
chargés du transfert sont surveillés par
satellite 1200 voyage comme celui ci
sont prévues entre les deux
bibliothèques en attendant l'ouverture
des salles de lecture en octobre
prochain tous les livres transportés
sont stockés en sous-sol à l'abri des
regards indiscrets
depuis la fin du 19ème siècle il
existait des compagnies de métro et
d'autobus privé à paris mais leur
nationalisation date d'il ya exactement
un demi-siècle la ratp fait donc en ce
moment ses 50 ans cinquante ans
d'évolutions techniques du poinçonneur
des lilas aux péages automatiques des
rames en bois au wagon à pneus reportage
nego vercia pierre moscovitch jours
la violence n'est pas venu vivre dans le
bus et c'était une partie de rigolade
ils adorent ça les anciens de la ratp
discuter sur un but sa plateforme du bon
vieux temps
le métro parisien est né avec le siècle
en 1900 voyageurs en sous sol c'est
alors une découverte un vrai plaisir
après la deuxième guerre mondiale les
années difficiles
l'argent manque le réseau des transports
parisiens doit absolument se moderniser
c'est la création en 1948 de la régie
autonome des transports parisiens
une seule compagnie progroup désormais
tous les réseaux de bus et de métro
puis c'est le bond technologique
à cette époque déjà six ans ram roulotte
en même temps une minute trente cinq
dates entre deux trains on ne fait guère
mieux aujourd'hui mais le progrès
technique sera fatale à certaines
professions
fini les poinçonneurs à la station des
lilas comme ailleurs poinçonneur des
glands
tant pis pour la nostalgie poinçonnage
automatique escaliers roulants premier
poste de commande centralisé la ratp est
fière de sa technologie première
simulation à la conquête du client car
il se fait rare il faut une nouvelle
politique commerciale en 1975 apparaît
la carte orange c'est le succès est
immédiat
11 millions de cartes sont vendues en un
an mais cela ne suffit pas l'air atp
veut aussi améliorer son image comme
tout le monde elle se lance dans la pub
quel sera le ticket pour l'an 2000 avec
38 mille salariés 21 milliards de francs
de budget son défi pour demain sera
l'indispensable création d'un réseau
entre les banlieues
la décision a été prise le grand prix de
france aura bien lieu finalement à
magny-cours un accord a été trouvé avec
la fédération internationale automobile
ce grand prix sera courue le 28 juin
prochain
si les mains le film le plus attendu de
la semaine sans aucun doute un film
réalisé par un petit studio américain et
qui a obtenu trois nominations aux
oscars d'hollywood sur un thème scabreux
boogie nights nous raconte les
mésaventures d'une star du cinéma
pornographique à partir d'une histoire
vraie un film drôle et émouvant à la
fois qu'ils ne tombent jamais dans la
vulgarité pourtant l exercice était
difficile parce qu'elle deschamps
christophe comment faire un film sur le
porno sans faire un film porno c'est le
pari réussi du réalisateur de boogie
nights et si nous invite à jouer les
voyeurs
c'est pour mieux pénétrer ce milieu
méconnu boogie nights nous entraîne en
californie en 1977 sur les traces d'un
jeune serveur dont les rêves de gloire
sur grand écran
rencontré jack corner producteur de
films pour adultes ne passeront le
réalisateur s'est inspiré en partie de
la vie de john rawls célèbre acteur de
films pornos crédité de plus de 14 mille
partenaires mort du sida en 88
même s'il ne connaît pas cette fin
tragique edit connaîtra la gloire puis
la chute trop d'argent de plaisir de
drogue trop vite dans cette industrie
tout peut devenir tellement démoralise
ans après vous démolir rapidement les
gens doivent vraiment se serrer les
coudes on va s'accrocher à tous où ils
comprennent vraiment ce que vous vivez
boogie nights évoque le porno des années
70 quand ses auteurs étaient persuadés
de faire de l'art quand le cas cette
vidéo n'avait pas encore transformé le x
en industrie le français david perry
l'un des plus célèbres acteurs
d'aujourd'hui avec plus de 400 films à
son actif compare le film au porno qu'il
connaît bien c'est entre les gens si les
emmener en est ce moment c'est ce que
j'aime dans ce métier c'est ce côté
grande famille combi tous ensemble ces
grandes dames pour dîner on dort tous
ensemble - avec relation chacun festival
hors caméra mais ça c'est sa santé tout
à fait ça d'abord le côté de mec est
passionné centre qui fait ses prières
des amoureux mais ce qu'ils font mais je
pense que dans les gens font de
l'industriel comment pelé va même
devenir le cclat c'est la boucherie ses
bras et lui ce matin là c'est mon film
et sans sida a considérablement changé
les choses
dans signe là
- ça peut vous gâcher mon avis
complètement con mais juste
jusqu'aujourd'hui on avoue élections
comme ça il ya des garanties
oui il ya dix postes mais bon le test
faut prendre qu'un jeu mais votre nom
j'en fais 50 dans 5 minutes à la photo
c'est une question de confiance entre
les mots pleins d'émotion mais aussi
d'humour nous dit nights ne juge ni ne
condamne c'est pourquoi il était films x
ce que le parent est à la mafia
l'évocation d'une famille avec ses
règles ses codes ses bas nuit ici
trahissant le couple gagnant du super
loto de 100 millions de francs s'est
fait connaître il s'agit d'un couple de
libourne en gironde lui et employés
l'essentiel sncf parlons elle est aide
soignante en fait tous les deux n'ont
pas encore très bien réalisé ce qui leur
est arrivé ils sont les deuxièmes plus
gros gagnant de l'histoire du lotto leur
premier rêve un voyage au canada voilà
avant de nous quitter le rappel du
principal titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi à propos des élections des
présidents de région et des élections
cantonales
l'ancien secrétaire général du rpr jean
françois mancel exclu du mouvement
gaulliste il avait accepté les avances
du front national dans son département
de l'oise
dans un instant la vidéo il avait le
martinet 20h50 un film de télévision
mirage noir chili à 22h47 discutent ce
n'est pas aujourd'hui que de là demain
7h 50 dans les 4 vérités françoise
laborde recevra le président de force
démocrate monsieur bon choix
by voilà je vous souhaite une excellente
jaurès une prochaine bonsoir à l'eau
oh